next week for the fourth year in a row
we're taking our show down to San Diego
yeah we're gonna be airing this has been
so much fun every year and it gets more
and more fun each time we're gonna be
airing a week of shows live from the
historic Spreckels theater we've got
lots of exciting stuff planned
incredible guests lined up including the
cash from the upcoming movie predator
gonna be with us the cast from the
upcoming movie glass a reunion of the
cast from Breaking Bad and the cast from
the movie Aquaman there's gonna be a lot
of fun other things we're gonna do a lot
of surprises
it's all happening these are not our
usual dates that we air it's all
happening Wednesday July 18th through
Sunday July 22nd ok Wednesday through
Sunday of next week and this is cool the
company that makes pop vinyl figures
Funko has once again once again created
four new limited-edition Conan pop
figures these are collectible vinyl
figures that we're giving out
exclusively to our audiences in San
Diego we've been doing this every year
check them out here we go there's this
one there's rebel pilot Conan which is
going to be available free yeah I guess
when there's predator Conan which
basically that's that basically depicts
me in high school with my asthma inhaler
yeah
can I take a bedpan okay there's ant-man
Conan and check it out there's a there's
a little tiny Conan
[Applause]
you're a choking hazard and finally a
choking hazard that's great thanks a lot
Andy and then Hellboy Coenen right there
so this is these are worth by the way
i've we've been on the internet after
we've given these away at comic-con and
these are worth several million dollars
once they or something like that i think
although this one is now this look this
one's slightly open oh my god it's
destroyed people freak out yeah yeah
slightly open because they're like it's
no longer
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
it's like you took a dump on the Sistine
Chapel no I put my DNA on it
now it's worth even more personally lick
each one make sure to check out it's
gonna be really fun make sure to check
out our comic-con shows ladies I'm gonna
have a good time
[Applause]
you